from a city steeped in espionage history
a story straight out of a cold war
thriller
a spy allegedly at the british embassy
in berlin german prosecutors broke the
news naming the suspect as david s
saying on at least one occasion he
forwarded documents obtained in the
course of his professional activities to
a representative of a russian
intelligence service
we don't know what level of access he's
got because his local contractor he's a
british citizen so that you know he
could easily have access to some very
sensitive material and even at the lower
levels working inside the embassy you
know this the current staff list
people's addresses their their mobile
telephone numbers their home emails are
all sensitive material so it is quite a
significant breach
this comes as relations between russia
and germany were already strained by the
attempted assassination of russian
dissident alexey navalny treated after
the incident by germany
german foreign minister heiko mass was
quick to condemn the alleged spying on
an ally on their turf he invited us
we take the information that the
detained person's intelligence activity
was carried out on behalf of a russian
intelligence agency extremely seriously
spying on a close ally on german soil is
absolutely unacceptable and we are in
full solidarity with our british friends
but in london britain's secret services
were playing down the news they've known
about all this for a while they said
in an era of cyber espionage and
computer hacking this was almost
nostalgic old school spying but still
effective say observers
the thing is that espionage never stops
and
you may remember sergey skripal who was
uh recruited by mi6 in spain
so they are doing it to each other and
it's really it's it's nothing special
it's a big achievement
of course to recruit someone in the
embassy
unlike the scribble poisoning britain's
response to this latest russian assault
may be more muted
it's part of diplomatic life say those
in the know
everyone's at it
and no one can get too upset